hey guys this is andrew from
shippingsensors.com so let me quickly
introduce myself
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong on the option
market and i've decided guys to make
some youtube videos because
i want to show you everything i do at
work all the different tools and
techniques that i use
that work for me and most importantly
guys i want to show you how to use it
yourself
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and basically how to make money on
the markets
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make an update on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
so amc guys i've done a lot of videos on
this
stock recently and i was basically
showing you that we you know we have the
volumes going lower
here we have this one two three four
five move up
that is correcting right now we are
looking for an abc and
the abc is actually happening guys all
right so here i was telling you careful
you know
i'm bullish guys just to make it clear
but i showed you that
you know my target is 35 i found it with
different
methods i saw a big option expiry in
june i don't see it in april may
so this is telling me that you know
things are going to happen but later
so for the short term neutral right now
i was slightly bearish
at this level because i was looking for
an abc we having this abc right now
but once again guys a real abc you have
the c wave that is lower so
going to 750 would actually make sense
for me before of course
a strong move up so we are actually
trying
to understand what is happening so let's
go on the shorter time frame
so we're looking for support levels that
are gonna tell us if yes or no we go to
715.
i have one that i can get just by the
lowest level in the most recent past is
880
and look what i have on the four hours
time frame which is the most important
one guys if you
don't know where to start always start
from the four hours time frame yes it's
the most used ones
is the one when you have the best
reactions so on the forest time frame
look at the 200 period moving average
the king of the moving average or maybe
the queen of the moving averages i mean
it's the most used one and it's the one
that is
actually giving you same the best
reactions and here
where is it it's roughly the same level
9
880 so all this area is actually an area
of support so maybe we're going to see
something like this on monday definitely
here the momentum is bearish guys all
right the macd is negative the magnitude
signal
is red so it's the difference between
the magnetic and the 9-day explanation
moving average of the macd itself this
is how the
macd signal is computed and it is red so
we are going lower so maybe we gonna see
something like this and here
bouncing back all right doing a one two
three four five maybe and the other
scenario that to me is more likely is
that
you know we go here and we break it guys
and we go here and then we start moving
higher
careful what is going to happen at the
880 level uh it's very interesting if we
break this one
on the four hours time frame so if we
trade between five and eight hours
so you have two candles on the four
hours time frame then we probably gonna
go
to 750 i mean i don't see what can hold
amc
to reach this level if we break 818
but ultimately of course guys it's gonna
come
back and trade higher and we're gonna go
to
probably 25 correct and 35 and then
we're gonna see what is happening
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and down button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i see you guys